our main story tonight
and i cannot believe i'm saying this is
donald trump
and i say that i say that knowing that
every time his name is said out loud
he has a shattering orgasm and look
look we have mostly ignored trump on
this show but he has now won
three states has been endorsed by chris
christie and paul show him leading most
super tuesday states which is a big deal
since 1988 every candidate who's won the
most dates on super tuesday
went on to become their party's nominee
so at this point donald trump
is america's back mole it may have
seemed
harmless a year ago but now that it's
gotten frighteningly bigger
it is no longer wise to ignore it
and i do understand why trump supporters
might like him he's unpredictable and
entertaining
just look how he went after marco rubio
on friday
did you ever see a guy sweat like this
it's rubio
that's what it
that's objectively funny
just as it was funny when a few years
ago he tweeted i would like to extend my
best wishes to all even the haters and
losers on this special date
september the 11th he wished haters and
losers a happy 9 11.
there is a part of me that even likes
this guy it's a part of me
i hate but it is a part of me
and if you are someone who's sick of the
party establishment he might seem like a
protest candidate with some attractive
qualities
we like him he tells it like it is he
says what he means
i i honestly believe he's telling the
truth he's funding his own campaign
nobody owns him he's aggressive
and he's strong and he's bold i think
he's an incredible
businessman if he runs the country like
he runs
his organization we will be in good
shape
donald trump can seem appealing until
you take a closer look
much like the lunch buffet at a strip
club or the nfl
or having a pet chimpanzee sure it seems
fun but someday
coco is gonna tear your limbs
off
because let's look at each of those
qualities those people listed
first he tells it like it is does he
because the website politifact checks 77
of his statements and rated
76 of them as varying degrees are false
and i've witnessed this firsthand he
once attacked my old boss by tweeting
if jon stewart is so above it all and
legit why did he change his name from
jonathan leibowitz
he should be proud of his heritage and
then two years later wrote i never
attacked dopey john stewart for his
phony last name
would never do that and then just last
year he claimed
falsely to have turned down an invite to
appear on this very boring show
and and who's he trying to impress with
that lie
our show's guests include sloths and
puppies
we're basically a petting zoo with a
desk
but but when we pointed out that he had
never been invited
this is how he responded all of a sudden
i see people saying that john oliver and
i'm saying john
oliver and i checked with my people he
asked me to be on the show four or five
times
and i i don't even hardly know who he
was i wouldn't know what he looks like
well look first first i wouldn't expect
him to know who i was although for his
inevitable angry tweet about this
segment i'll tell him what i look like
i look like a neo-sighted parrot who
works at a bank but
but secondly secondly it was genuinely
destabilizing to be on the receiving end
of a lie that confidence
i even checked to make sure that no one
had even accidentally invited him
and of course they hadn't and i'm not
even sure
he knows he's lying i think he just
doesn't care about what the truth is
donald trump views the truth like this
lemur views the supreme court vacancy
i don't care about that in any way
please off i have a banana
so so let's move on let's move on to his
next
selling point that he is truly
independent and not beholden to anyone
or as he puts it
i'm self-funding my campaign i tell the
truth how much have you spent so far
probably 20 25 million dollars okay
let's break that down
first i'm rich therefore i tell the
truth has the same internal logic as i'm
a vegan therefore i know
karate there is no cause and effect
between those two
and the correlation usually goes the
other way
and and while it is true that he hasn't
taken corporate money the implication
that he has personally spent
20 to 25 million dollars is a bit of a
stretch
because what he's actually done is
loaned his own campaign
seventeen and a half million dollars and
has just personally given
just two hundred and fifty thousand
dollars and that's important
because up until the convention he can
pay himself back for the loan with
campaign funds
and if you don't think there's a
significant difference between a gift
and a loan
try giving your spouse an anniversary
loan and see how that goes
and even he himself sometimes admits
that his campaign is by no means
completely self-funded
i'm self-funding my campaign other than
the little tiny ones where they send in
you know women send in we had a woman
7.59
what do you do how can you send the
money back you know it's it's not it's
cute
it's beautiful they feel invested in
your campaign he makes it sound like
women are stuffing grimy dollar bills in
envelopes
writing donald trump on the front and
he's just too kind to send them back
but he's taken in seven and a half
million dollars in
individual contributions and if he
didn't want it maybe he shouldn't have
had
two donate buttons on his website
because money isn't unsolicited when you
have to ask for someone's credit card
expiration date to receive it
okay so so how about the claim that he
is tough well again
i'm not sure about that because for a
tough guy he has incredibly thin skin
back in 1988 spy magazine called him a
short fingered bulgarian
and ever since the edited graydon carter
says he receives envelopes from trump
always with a photo on which he circled
his hand to highlight the length of his
fingers
usually with a note reading c not so
short and look look his fingers
seem fine but the very fact he's so
sensitive about them
is absolutely hilarious as is the fact
that those notes were apparently written
in gold sharpie which is so
quintessentially donald trump
something that gives the passing
appearance of wealth but is actually
just a cheap tool
now now trump's trump's signature
his signature tough talk often involves
lawsuits he
loves to threaten to sue people like he
did with rosie o'donnell
she said i was bankrupt i never went
bankrupt so
probably i'll sue her because it would
be fun i'd like to take some money out
of her fat ass pockets
well look look look of course of course
he needs to take rosie o'donnell to
court
to take money out of her pockets because
his tiny tiny fingers
are too short to reach into her wallet
but
but he never sued her he never sued
rosie o'donnell in fact he's repeatedly
threatened people with lawsuits and not
followed through
including the rapper mac miller lawrence
o'donnell
vanity fair and an activist who launched
a petition for macy's
to drop trump's products i'll sue you is
trump's version of bazinga
it doesn't really mean anything but he
says it all the time
but perhaps trump's biggest selling
point as a candidate is his success
and where could people get that idea
from i'm really rich
i actually think i have the best
temperament people love me
and you know what i've been very
successful everybody loves me
i went to an ivy league school i'm very
highly educated
i know words i have the best words
oh please literally the biggest word in
the sentence
i have the best words is the word words
well it's worth noting while yes he has
made more money than most of us will
make in a lifetime
not only did he get a multi-million
dollar inheritance from his father
but he's also lost a huge amount and
this
is where we need to be careful because
as we've learned he will
he will threaten to sue your fat ass
pockets with his cocktail sausage
fingers
if you talk about his company's
bankruptcies so i will just let his own
daughter describe the state of his
finances at one point in his life
i remember once my father and i were
walking down fifth avenue
and there was a homeless person sitting
um
sitting right outside of trump tower and
i remember my father pointing to him and
saying
you know that guy has eight billion
dollars more than me because he was in
such extreme debt at that point you know
and that really shows you the
indomitable spirit of donald trump
to fall to his lowest point and in that
very moment
still find a way to be kind of a dick to
a homeless guy
now now his campaign claims his current
worth is in excess of 10
billion and they've written it in all
caps so it must be true
but others have disputed that figure in
fact a book once suggested that trump
might be worth a mere 150 to 250 million
dollars which trump protested
by suing the writer for five billion
dollars
which is a pretty roundabout way of
getting half the way to 10 billion
and you should know for the record trump
lost that lawsuit
twice but i am glad that he sued if only
because during the deposition
he explained that his estimate of his
net worth fluctuates based on
and i quote feelings even my own
feelings
and that can change rapidly from day to
day
think about that he claimed that his net
worth changes depending on his mood
which makes absolutely no sense partly
because he always seems to be in the
same mood specifically smog yet gassy
and interestingly interestingly
a significant portion of his
self-valuation is intangible
his brand is what he values uh very much
and he on his his disclosure form that
he's released
it's about three billion dollars that's
what he values his brand as
exactly he values his own name at three
billion dollars
and i'm not saying a name can't have
value it's why people will pay 120
for a plain white t-shirt that is
designed by kanye west
they don't want just any white t-shirts
they want one designed by a bored
sociopath with a finger free anus
but the three billion dollars
seems a bit high especially because
while trump has said
if i put my name on something you know
it's gonna be good
over the years his name has been on some
things that have arguably been
very ungood including trump shuttle
uh which no longer exists trump vodka
which was discontinued
trump magazine which folded trump world
magazine which also folded
trump university over which he's being
sued and of course the travel booking
site
go trump.com whose brief existence was i
imagine a real thorn in the side of
anyone hoping
gotrump.com featured a single thing
worth masturbating to
and that's not even mentioning this
when it comes to great steaks i've just
raised the steaks
trump steaks are the world's greatest
steaks and i mean that in
every sense of the word and the sharper
image is the only
store where you can buy them and
not only can you not buy those stakes
anymore but why did he sell them at the
sharper image
that is a weird choice i will take a
massage chair
an indoor waterfall and eight and a half
pounds of the finest
meat in america and sure every business
executive is bound to have a few
missteps but trump's lack of sound
financial instincts is perhaps best
exemplified
by the business that he put his name on
back in 2006
just before the entire housing market
collapsed
i think it's a great time to start a
mortgage company we're gonna have a
great company it's trump mortgage and
trumpmortgage.com
and it's gonna be a terrific company
yeah it wasn't
in fact in fact starting a mortgage
company in 2006 was one of the worst
decisions you could possibly make
but i guess you can convince yourself it
was a good idea when you say
30 words and five of them are great
great terrific
trump and trump and you might say well
never mind side businesses what he
really is
is a builder but a building with trump
written on it is not necessarily owned
by him he may have just
licensed his name to them something he
claims is actually better
than ownership you don't put up money
you don't put up
anything smoking like a true builder
and and some of those licensed buildings
sell his reputation hard like the sales
video for the trump ocean resort
in northern mexico i'm very very proud
of the fact that when i build i have
investors that follow me
all over people ask me what does trump
stand for more than
anything else and if i use one word it's
always
quality right but it's easy to throw
around the word
quality have you ever stayed at a
quality inn
the pillows are stuffed with hair they
fished out of the bathtub drake
he was never the builder for that
project which was later abandoned
leaving would-be condo buyers like
william flint who lost 168 thousand
dollars
feeling understandably betrayed donald
trump was an expert in in these types of
projects or so we
thought in a deposition for a lawsuit
regarding the property
trump's son donald trump jr conceded
that the trump brand could lead people
to think a project was a solid
investment
there's one of the things that you've
learned through this process is that
the trump name brings stability and our
viability
to the project i don't know if it brings
stability or viability but
i imagine certain people feel that and
that might actually be the most honest
slogan for the trump campaign
trump 2016 i don't know if it brings
stability or viability
but i imagine certain people feel that
now not only not only did investors in
that property sue donald trump they also
did in trump
tower tampa another project that never
got off the ground and in both cases
trump characteristically deflected blame
onto the developers
and you would think those investors
would be facing an up impossible
legal battle given trump's tough talk
when i get sued i i take it right all
tits take it all the way you know what
happens
if you settle suits you get sued more
it's true
i don't settle anything i don't settle
guess what
he settled both those cases but the
problem is
even when you can demonstrably prove
trump to be wrong it somehow never seems
to matter
you can hold his feet to the fire but
he'll just stand there on the stumps
bragging about his fireproof foot skin
and that may be because he has spent
decades turning
his own name into a brand synonymous
with success
and quality and he's made himself the
mascot for that brand like
ronald mcdonald or chef boyardee and
that is who we have seen in the
apprentice
or wrestlemania or home alone too
but if he's actually going to be the
republican nominee it's time to stop
thinking of the mascot and start
thinking of the man
because a candidate for president needs
a coherent set of policies
whatever you think about marco rubio and
ted cruz at least you basically know
where they stand
but trump's opinions have been wildly
inconsistent he's been pro-choice
and pro-life for and against assault
weapon bans
in favor of both bringing in syrian
refugees and deporting them out of the
country
and that inconsistency can be troubling
just this morning for instance
he was asked about the fact that david
duke former grand wizard of the ku klux
klan
had told supporters to vote for him and
this was his answer
will you unequivocally condemn david
duke and say that you don't want his
vote or that of other white supremacists
in this election
well just so you understand i don't know
anything about david duke okay
i don't know anything about what you're
even talking about with the
white supremacy or white supremacist
honestly i don't know david duke i don't
believe i've ever met him i'm pretty
sure i didn't meet him and i just don't
know anything about him
really that's your best answer there
because
you definitely know who he is partly
because you called him a bigot and a
racist in the past
but that's not even the point
the point is with an
answer like that you are either racist
or you are pretending to be
and at some point there is no difference
there and sure
he disavowed david duke later in the day
but the scary thing is
we have no way of knowing which of his
inconsistent views
he will hold in office will he stand by
a statement that
vaccines are linked to autism or his
belief that mexico is sending us rapists
oh and
what about that plan he had to defeat
isis we're fighting a very politically
correct
war well we see that the other thing is
with the terrorists you have to take out
their families
when you get these terrorists you have
to take out their families
they they care about their lives don't
kid yourself but they say they don't
care about their lives you have to take
out their families
that is the frontrunner for the
republican nomination
advocating a war crime and he might say
he was joking or he's changed his mind
about any of these things and private
individuals
are allowed to change their minds we all
do it but when he's sworn in as
president
on january 20th 2017 on that day
his opinions are going to matter and you
will remember that date
because it's the one that time travelers
from the future will come back to to try
and stop the whole thing
from happening and listen i
get i get that the character of donald
trump
is entertaining and that he says things
that people want to hear and i know his
very name is powerful
just listen to this one supporter
explain what it means to her
i was a little girl right i didn't even
know what trump towers were
but i knew that he was a wealthy
successful man somehow like there was a
even as a very young kid the word trump
sort of meant rich
it meant success she's not even wrong
trump does
sound rich it's almost onomatopoeic
trump it's the sound produced when a
mouthy servant is slapped across the
face
with a wad of thousand dollar bills
trump
it's the sound of a cork popping on a
couple's champagne adversary
the date renovations in the wine cellar
were finally completed
the very name trump is the cornerstone
of his brand
if only there were a way to uncouple
that magical word
from the man he really is well guess
what
there is because it turns out the name
trump was not always his family's name
one biographer found that a prescient
ancestor had changed it from
and this is true trump yes
drug and drug
is much less magical it's the sound
produced
when a morbidly obese pigeon flies into
the window of a foreclosed old navy
drunk it's the sound of a bottle of
store-brand root beer falling off the
shelf in a gas station mini mart
and it may seem weird to bring up his
ancestral name
but to quote donald trump he should be
proud of his heritage
because trump is much more reflective of
who he actually
is so if you are thinking of voting for
donald trump
the charismatic guy promising to make
america great again
stop and take a moment to imagine how
you would feel
if you just met a guy named donald trump
a litigious serial liar with a string of
broken business ventures
and the support of a former clan leader
who he can't decide whether or not to
condemn
would you think he would make a good
president or is the spell now somewhat
broken
and that is why tonight i'm asking
america to make donald trump again
hashtag make donald trump again
we've actually filed paperwork to
trademark
the name drunk and incidentally when we
own it
i will have the best word and
and if you go to donald j trump.com
which we own
you can download a trophenator chrome
extension which will replace the word
trump
with trump wherever it appears in your
browser and you can also buy
these make donald trump again hats
which we are selling at cost meaning
we've chosen not to make a profit
a fact which will probably irritate mr
drumpf more than anything else i've said
tonight
and if you're thinking well that's all
great but i wish there was a new
campaign anthem for donald trump
well here it is now here it is right now
because listen we cannot keep
getting blinded by the magic of his name
we need to see him through fresh eyes so
please
don't think of him as donald trump think
of him
and don't vote for him because he tells
it like it is
he's a artist don't vote for
him because he's tough
he's a baby with even smaller fingers
don't vote for him because he's a
builder he's more of a shitty lifestyle
brand
and that is our show mr trump
i await your lawsuit in the morning i
have no doubt
the complaint will be signed in gold
sharpie
good night
trump